for joining me now is Tim shovel the
chief negotiator at Network Royal team
traveler good morning to you thanks for
being with us so how close are you guys
to to getting a deal
well we made really significant progress
in December
um when we put a new offer on the table
that was worth nine percent over two
years no compulsory redundancies for
2025 and a whole lot of other things
that the union had been asking for
including privileged travel
um and two of the three unions accepted
that and we know with some quite High
results from our employees who voted for
the deal even though rmt suggested they
shouldn't vote for that deal so we think
that they were on the right path here
um and that with some clarification
There's an opportunity to to to to
resubmit that deal so you're going to
resubmit the deal you're not going to
improve the deal that's on the table
well I think there's a clarification
Point here I think the as I say we know
that some some of our people were they
were asked by the rmt to do a referendum
in just five days which wasn't long
enough we we'd agreed with them in full
you know expected a two-week referendum
in five days that meant that some of our
employees had to answer a question are
they going to vote for their strike or
not against a recommendation from the
IMT to reject the deal so we think
there's an opportunity to spend a little
bit more time going around those
questions understanding the points of
concern uh that that weren't fully
understood by that by some of our staff
reclarifying those and then ask them to
have the vote again absolutely well this
is your chance now to clarify some of
those points that you think aren't being
understood by those rmt members
yeah so for example within the
maintenance reform part of the deal
there's some quite significant
um uh improvements that were available
for example we've put a new contract on
the table which allows some of our
employees to gain on top of the normal
nine percent pay award they could gain
from some benefits associated with that
new contract I think there was a lot of
concern about that that hadn't been
fully recognized as to how much that
could be worth on an individual basis so
that's a really good example something
we want to clarify
and on compulsory redundancies you've
put it off until 2025 but that still
doesn't give people a great amount of
job security does it and there are going
to be Cuts people are going to lose
their jobs uh once this is resolved
well we need to reduce our establishment
by about 1850 heads um 850 posts need to
leave the organization we've got 3 000
volunteers for voluntary Severance so
whilst we've guaranteed there'll be no
compulse redundances to January 2025 at
the earliest there's no suggestion that
then there would be at that point
because as I say we've got you know over
a thousand more people volunteering to
leave than we actually want to so you
know we don't think there's any chance
of people being made compulsory
redundant I mean Mr Shelby you're making
it seem like it's really clear and it
should just be signed away so where's
the hold up here Mick Lynch says that
the government have been getting
involved in and putting stymieing the
deal putting a block on stuff is that
right
well look we're in a different place
between the train companies and network
rail we've got Pat we have uh parallel
but separate negotiations
um we have a a different offer on the
table from that from the train companies
so uh I'm not going to comment on those
other those other negotiations but in
terms of our deal that we've got a
significant reform we think we're nearly
there
um we can see that from the way that 36
percent of our employees from from the
rmt voted yes for the deal even though
they'd been advised not to by the Trade
union so we do think there's a you're on
the right path and we're going to keep
going with that and we'll look forward
to meeting the RMC just as soon as these
strikes are over okay well those Strokes
will continue for the next few days but
they say there will be talks soon all
right Tim Sherman appreciate your time
with us